es geht um migration und integration
es geht um den satz 2015 darf sich nicht
wiederholen
und ich stelle die frage was gab sich
eigentlich nicht wiederholen dass wir
menschen in not aufgenommen haben darf
sich wiederholen dass ortskräfte in
afghanistan die jahrelang mit uns
gearbeitet haben nach deutschland zu
sich in sicherheit gebracht werden da
sich wieder wohl aber es gibt vier
punkte die dürfen sich auf keinen fall
wiederholen
und ich hoffe dass unsere regierung
eigentlich die lehren aus 2015 gelernt
hat einmal die unkontrollierte menschen
die aus einer kriegssituation kommen
sind herzlich willkommen menschen aber
die auf die welle steigen aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen nach europa
kommen oder mit falschen identitäten
hier kommen dürfen das darf sich nicht
wiederholen
terroranschläge wie in würzburg in
berlin in hamburg köln das silvester
nach wo hunderte von frauen sexuell
belästigt wurden
ehrenmorde
meinungsfreiheit ablehnung wie wir
november 2020 auch hier in berlin
gesehen haben auch von flüchtlingen
antisemitischer demos wo auch
flüchtlinge teilgenommen haben dürfen
sich nicht wiederholen und da sind wir
schon beim thema integration dann das
konzept der integration ist nicht will
glaube ich noch nicht angekommen bei den
politiker viele meinten das sollte
sprache plus arbeiten - kriminalität
seien aber das reicht nicht für
integration gehört auch die emotional
ist das emotionale ankommen in
deutschland die verinnerlichung der
werte und vor allem das begreifen dass
in deutschland eine historische
verantwortung vor allem was das thema
antisemitismus angeht darf sich auch
noch etwas nicht wiederholen und zwar
die spaltung der gesellschaft der
migrationspolitik betreibt muss die
bevölkerung mitnehmen da muss sie
aufklären muss ihnen klar machen warum
wir so was tun die spaltung weiter aus
und hat dazu geführt dass wir eine
rechtsradikale
bundes partei haben dass wir fast nicht
in der lage sind über das thema zu reden
dass das thema tabu geworden ist dass
diejenigen die vielleicht eine andere
meinung als der menschen sind alles
unmoralisch betitelt werden und
außerhalb des diskurses gedrängt werden
das sind vier punkte die fisch natürlich
nicht wiederholen sollen alles anders
dürfen wir diskutieren
wenn man so ist ein schlauer mann und
ist ja in einem think tank der der cdu
sehr nahe steht und jetzt ein bisschen
die cdu neu aufladen soll dass es auch
gut denn das hat sie wirklich nötig was
er sagt können wir zum teil natürlich
unterschreiben deswegen sagt dass auch
antisemitismus darf sich hier nicht weit
machen dass ich nicht wiederholen keiner
auch kein flüchtling darf dass sie auf
die straßen tragen ist jeder herzlich
bei ihnen ist ja auch klar aber
gleichzeitig bringen sie so ein bisschen
ein ihre argumentation dinge die
natürlich die gesellschaft auch spalten
weil sie suggerieren
natürlich haben die flüchtlinge was mit
terroranschlägen zu tun sie sagen dieser
unkontrollierten zuzug der darf sich
nicht wiederholen ja wo wiederholt er
sich denn wer wiederholt sich doch nicht
es gibt ausnahmen dieser paar
afghanistan flüchtlinge die angekommen
sind ohne die richtigen papiere in einer
absoluten notsituation keinen
unkontrollierten zuzug mehr weil die
alle über die türkei kommen oder
sonstwer und kontrolliert werden ein
außengrenzen europas deswegen was mich
stört bei ihrer argumentation ist ein
spalter ist allem element ich weiß nicht
warum sie das machen denn die menschen
die hier sind haben sich doch zum großen
teil hervorragend integriert gerade die
nächste generation ich sehe dass selbst
über so ein bäcker wo ich bin arbeitet
jemand der aus thüringen kommt er konnte
am anfang gar kein deutsch heute
schmeißt er den ganzen laden und solche
fälle gibt es zuhauf natürlich gibt es
die pflicht die sprache zu erlernen sich
zu integrieren und hier sich dann
tatsächlich auch voll einzubringen
unsere kultur anzuerkennen dann können
wir nämlich bestätigt aber das ist nicht
so ein mittel aber gleichzeitig sollte
man nicht so tun als seien hier nur
terroristen oder dergleichen unter denen
die hier sich und auch nicht ein solches
fremming betreiben denn das ist das was
sie tun nein das tue ich nicht ich
arbeite mit vielen vielen flüchtlinge
tagtäglich und ich treffe auch die
großartige gut integrierter menschen ist
und wie wenig tauglich natürlich ich
arbeite mit denen ich bin auch
zuwanderer der dazu gekommen ist aber
wenn sie die kriminalstatistik anschauen
will wie schauen wo die schwierigkeiten
diese menschen die nach deutschland
gekommen sind ich rede nicht darüber ich
arbeite mit diesen menschen ich gehe
ihre gedanken basieren darüber nein aber
natürlich weil die probleme gibt es und
das alles einfach alles spaltung
darzustellen weil ich über probleme
spreche dass es mir zu wenig und
eigentlich auch wieder polemisch dann
die probleme sind da ich meine was
brauchen sie noch damit wir endlich
begreifen dass wir ein problem mit
gleichberechtigung unter vielen
muslimischen flüchtlinge ich rede hier
nicht von den türkischen zweiten dritten
generation da gibt es andere probleme zb
wie viele erdogan gut finden oder wie
viel zum beispiel die wieder
veröffentlichung der karikaturen
ablehnen und damit auch die meinung
firma ist sind viele haben mir ist nicht
nur sagen
es geht um die werte und die sind teil
dieser integration deshalb spreche ich
diese unterschiedlich aber sie sagen
2015 da wird sich nicht darf sich nicht
wiederholen wiederholt sich doch gar
nicht das bis jetzt nicht aber das ist
gerade beim tennis ich fand das sehr
spannend
machte er weiter ich habe noch viele
punkte die ich wiedersehe
spezialist aus schweiz werde ich den
neutralen
selbstverständlich einbringen
bei meiner ganzen unerschöpflichen
bewunderung wie béla anda finde ich
jetzt ihr statement das tape wieder
etwas zu hart gegenüber hermann so den
ich nämlich kennengelernt habe und
schätzen gelernt habe als einen wirklich
ich muss auf einen realisten in diesem
thema der migration dass wir mit sehr
vielen tabus behaftet ist in einem punkt
allerdings möchte ich eine etwas
optimistischere deutung anbieten als die
die sie gebracht haben sie haben gesagt
diese migration sein ich ein tabuthema
und wenn ich zurückblicke an die zeit in
die zeit in der ich damals in
deutschland gearbeitet habe sie mir das
thema migration
kriminelle ausländer dass also der
ausländer der migrant der flüchtlinge
nicht einfach quasi der ganz dass das
edelste lebewesen per se ist und man
sich schon fast heilig diese situation
hat sich verändert also heute erlebe ich
deutschland darum dass sie haben eine
realitätsbezogenen diskussion über die
probleme der migration natürlich auch
aufgrund der probleme auch grund
aufgrund auch von personen und
persönlichkeiten wie ihnen er morgens
sie bringen das hinein und wenn ich auf
2015 zurückblicke dann muss ich etwas
sorgen um diese runde hier etwas zu
provozieren sehr stark kritisiert wurde
ja immer kanzlerin merkel und die wurde
ja unglaublich geräte die sie für diese
2015 der grenzöffnung obwohl damals sehr
viele gejubelt sage ich etwas positiv
ist über freue
mich einfach gefragt was wäre eigentlich
die automotive gewesen für eine deutsche
kanzlerin für einen deutschen kanzler in
diesem moment hätten die jetzt
schäferhunde an die grenze und die
außengrenze der eu schicken sollen gsg9
einsatzkommandos mit schweren waffen die
diese flüchtlinge migranten nach
wirtschaftsmigranten zurückgebracht
haben man muss eben auch sehen dass die
europäischen länder die eu länder die
deutschen sehr heuchlerisch kritisiert
haben die haben nämlich die deutschen
noch etwas im regen stehen lassen die
haben alle gesagt ja so schön wenn die
deutschen da ein bisschen vormachen aber
ihr benehmen dann gar niemanden auch bei
uns darf niemand rein kommen und man hat
sozusagen den deutschen diese last
übertragen die natürlich auch aus der
geschichte heraus eine gewisse
verpflichtung abgekoppelt
reinhold aus der ddr geschiedene die
natürlich gern an der merkel geleitet
hat als damals viktor orban nicht gesagt
hat er weg mit den flüchtlingen und
schickt sie alle nach deutschland stand
sie vor der frage was mache ich muss nur
den wenigen chancen die fährt geschichte
gehört auch natürlich dass wir
bestimmte faschistische ideologie auch
nicht reinlassen und vor allem wenn auch
bestimmte leute antisemitisch
eingestellt sind und das haben wir schon
in der letzten fünf sechs jahren massiv
auch teilweise teilweise gefährlich ist
antisemitismus ein deutscher herkunft
übergreifens auch ein deutsches problem
aber es gibt leute die aus syrien aus
afghanistan gekommen mit denen ich
arbeite und bei dem thema haben wir ein
anderes anderer meinung und das gehört
auch zur wahrheit genauso wie natürlich
natürlich wissen wir aber das hat dass
ich einen platz
unter den wir uns alle das steht völlig
außer frage ich habe auch ein bisschen
problem damit mit der argumentation wenn
man das immer im vordergrund stellt es
klingt schon immer so mit das wirklich
alles schlecht war und jeder der
reinkommt es schlimm das stimmt ja nicht
will hat es deutlich angesprochen die
überwältigende mehrheit lebt ja
friedlich hier im land und ist auch an
der integration interessiert natürlich
integration und das hier richtig
natürlich gibt es auch sehr sehr viele
schwarze fälle und da vielen jahren den
einsatz mehrerer machen aus 2015 müssen
wir gelernt haben gerade jetzt beim
zuzug aus afghanistan wie feind tischen
geht die besser und schneller raus ihr
dann wir auch nur daraus zwischen ihre
zeitung hat darüber berichtet dass
diejenigen die am flugzeugen saßen die
mehrheit davon teilweise nicht
ortskräfte worden und nicht die ja in
einer absoluten rotation hat wird sich
dass man sich auf den 12 wir haben es
diesmal halt auch die flüchtlinge
begleitet die damals kamen aus syrien
und den landweg gemacht haben in einer
großartigen reportage verteuerung
hundertmal und auch in der tasche
bekommen und diese leute haben sich hier
hervorragend
gegen diese übermacht da auf der anderen
seite muss ich ganz klar ihn hier
verteidigen also das ist jetzt für mich
nein das ist für mich jetzt etwas
lichterketten rhetorik er weil die
aufgabe der politik die aufgabe der
medien besteht ja nicht darin zu jubeln
wie großartig die
man muss natürlich die missstände
aufdecken und zuständen hatte doch
endlich und das ist für mich da und
jetzt sind wir beide bei der
schattenseite dieser ganzen geschichte
das sind natürlich schon viele probleme
importiert worden und wir beobachten im
moment wieder das ist mein eindruck von
außen die ferndiagnose dass es wieder
etwas angespannt die diskussion diese
themen aufs tapet zu bringen das zeigt
auch diese diskussion kam so auch themen
so etwas haben wir sofort nein also
diese teams
haben
[Musik]